you're gonna see one side who wants to
pick someone like a coy way to be their
champion and you're gonna have another
side who says well really the most
worthy champion maybe in this new
generation is kill monger you have to
turn to a face people trust and that's a
vacuum this is how we we kind of
backfill Namor into the ncu I think it's
a great way that you have Atlantis you
have Wakanda
you have two of these kind of like very
proud and tribal nations going
head-to-head
[Music]
okay welcome back to the rock stars this
is rogue Theory quarantine edition
obviously things are a little different
but that doesn't stop us we've still
we've been doing these hangouts just
pitching wild theories at each other and
then we were like let's just record
these make this our episode of rogue
theory and here with me to get into some
crazy theories of course Eric Voss from
the blue dungeon I'm here and I still
have a couple breaths of air left sweet
we also have Tommy Bechtold hey thanks
for the contribution Tommy
there's a little lag just kidding making
that just annoying because you do have
lag so if you're faking lag is doubly
lag no lag gags it's impossible to get
that timing right all right and no one
cares about any other guests yeah guys
excuse me it's my good friend Matt Rob
smoosh thanks for having me what we
already had to cut Emily from this
episode that's right because I'm Phillip
Melina and we're about to get into what
happened to our favorite African country
during the snap what happened to these
Kenyan relatives sad yeah the People's
Republic of Congo no we're talking what
condo will happen and what conduct what
happened will happen
okay so we've been rewatching all of the
MCU movies help us get us through
quarantine you can join us in that in
discord by the way if you're a patron
and I just watch along with us in there
but you also heard me talk about this a
big question we realize what happened in
Wakanda at the snap five years pass we
know that T'Challa their leader is gone
we also know that his sister also dusted
but we see a Koi a representing Wakanda
in that like Hollow meeting in endgame
and I was like wait who is in charge of
Wakanda then what is going on in Wakanda
is there like game of Wakanda happening
and she's talking all about this
underwater earthquake and it's keep
be nightmares about this and so I want
to know guys give me your theories on
what happened in Wakanda over those five
years
let's go rogue okay so yeah there was
this discussion of this like underwater
earthquake and really what was
interesting to me is a koi a stone she
was like we handle it by not handling it
which made it sound like back off this
is a wakandan issue we got this under
control so what I think we're gonna see
is like an inner conflict within the
borders of Wakanda as like society is
starting to turn on each other after
this power vacancy because yeah not only
do you have to Cholly gone you have
Cherie gone as well the entire royal
families gone if you're going by
traditional lineage rules it might go
back up to the Queen Mother Ramon de but
really we know what kind of goes by
these trial by combat it warrior falls
and then the run think that Queen Mother
got in a trial by combat she be vicious
Angela Bassett would and has cut a [ __ ]
for sure she wait and exhale all this
time yeah so one of the big mysteries
that still hasn't been answered in the
MCU is what happened to the people when
they dusted it's been implied that it's
just like a blackout and they don't
really have any memories during that
time but we know in what Condon
mythology they go to the ancestral plane
when they die and they live on it's
these Panther spirit guides to the next
generation of people so I'm wondering if
in Wakanda we're gonna start to see kind
of this almost like Greek god oversight
over the current drama and you're gonna
see a division between the ancestors
spirits and they're each gonna have a
champion for who they think is the
rightful ruler of the next generation of
Lokhande and you're gonna have a
division between the people who were
dusted who are maybe in this limbo state
who don't really belong in the ancestral
plane because they died in this
unnatural way and the people who died a
natural way like to Chaka and like the
other ancestors that de chollet commune
with and you're gonna see one side who
wants to pick someone like a coy way to
be their champion and you're gonna have
another side who says well really the
most worthy champion maybe in this new
generation is
kill monger is indeed jakka and they're
going to resurrect him using maybe some
of the heart-shaped herb and it's gonna
play out on this other layer of drama
its gonna be like Game of Thrones
Wakanda where you see like kill monger
versus a co a to battle for the wakandan
throne how are they community ancestral
Plains Lion King say sex yeah but no
Eric how are they doing it well and in
the same way that a child commune with
them he got buried in the in the soil or
in those in the magical sand and he
consumed the heart-shaped herb and he
went to this ancestral plane and that's
what he did after the warrior falls it's
all part of that ritual so on each side
we're having two separate rituals and
each side is communion with these
different aspects of the ancestral plane
but also it could be like two happening
and they just talk to plants mm-hmm yeah
and so when they go in there suddenly it
goes from like a place that you know had
some people to it's jam-packed with half
of the people from Wakanda yeah half of
the people from Wakanda and we don't
know if it's exactly half right like
that's half of all life it could just be
like twelve people from what condo and
it's like everyone in New Jersey so then
here's here's something that I think is
really interesting about that idea isn't
the ancestral plane filled with all the
past Black Panthers yes it's all the
people who are part of that that lineage
so then technically the people that
could be buying for that side could be
just Black Panthers from every time yeah
and they may all have like different
outlooks on who is the worthy astride
'full leader of the country especially
after you know you could argue that
after T'Challa ascended to the throne
and he was able to fend off both mbaku
and kill Munger and then right after
that Thanos arrived and like rocked
Wakanda and took out half of all life
like some of those ancestors may argue
you know what we need a different kind
of leadership and we may need someone
who's tougher and more militaristic to
defend Wakanda and defend Earth from any
future threats and you could see some
people making the argument that kill
Mike or maybe the guy for the job all
right I'm giving
you Rogi there the road yeah I'm giving
you one Rogge for the idea of just the
ancestral plane alone being a whole
movie in there with a bunch of my Black
Panthers and stuff and then another
Rogie because there's a fight between
the dead and the living for rule of
Wakanda and I think that's awesome sets
two rogue E's but I need you to find two
things in your blue dungeon right now to
represent the two rogue E's on your end
because I didn't send you any okay in
fact if everyone can just grab things
that will be your Rogi so you can keep
count and you you know I'm I might be
very generous you might need 15 of these
things okay so I did everybody grab
something that will represent the
rugby's you don't to show me now yep
great all right Eric what do you got I
got a clamp that I found and then I got
a chunk of the blue dungeon wall I
helped me set up that blue dungeon and
that clamp was essential Oh
all right who's next I'll go next
great Tommy alright what was going on
those five years in Wakanda
well Philip guess who's back back again
Jews back pocket Oh some friends from
Bach who's back and back who's back
dubaku's back I created a monster
because nobody wants to see it's already
we already shouldn't really be talking
too much about what Kondo without any
representation on this panel yes at
least you went to the white rapper yeah
I don't what was wrong with Marshall
Mathers banger
it's a Baku the pride of Brighton New
York mr. Duke
you're not from Brooklyn buddy you're
from Brighton it's okay we all know we
know you graduated in 2002 same as me
what we love you think he's from
Brooklyn yeah we're the two most famous
people from Rochester I would know okay
so listen let's talk about why this
makes sense it's logic another white
rapper it's logical that the biggest
strongest man in Wakanda would then
assume the throne through the trial by
combat okay like we're at a time we need
a leader to step up people are dusting
all over people are dusting dusting like
people okay so what you need is someone
to step up and lead you need a man or a
woman you know who can come in with
brute-force win that trial by combat and
give the people something to believe in
okay so that's Ibaka he's strong he's
confident he's compassionate he knows
when help is needed
he's I think a vegetarian or at least a
pescetarian and I like that he's woke so
yeah I think big strong beefy boy mbaku
is new king black Tommy this isn't a
you're not trying to get us to vote for
him what happened in those five years
let's take a look so you have you have
to Charlie use the Black Panther is the
king of Wakanda people adore him he goes
through this crisis with kill monger
will care where kill Monga she defeats
him and takes over then he in turn
defeats kill memory so we're already in
some instability then what happens a few
months later the man turns to dust like
Brad Pitt at the end of interview with a
vampire he just turns to dust and falls
to the earth so what are people to do
now we're in chaos for the second time
and not too many years you have to turn
to a face people trust and that's mbaku
second place so close to first the
strongest opposition he might face in
terms of a match would be acquire a but
I think at this point he probably he
probably has to face an open trial again
so like what we would see is maybe maybe
five or six candidates step up from the
different tribes in Wakanda to go and
try and face him but we know that he's
barely less strong than T'Challa right
so he's gonna beat all of them so we'd
probably see him beat them and then he's
got to like the one thing that we didn't
see a lot out of him was brain so he's
gonna have to figure out how to utilize
all this technology and that's where you
know we might see some suicide directors
covered you know I mean like it's like
you know me a big strong guy yeah I
forever to get into Google hangout today
because I'm just not used to be
acknowledged II I'm super strong and
confident but maybe the tech isn't right
there for me so well I'm a natural
leader and people adore me maybe I'm not
able to hook up a computer that's kind
of what I think about who's that yeah
you got that white guy confidence where
you just say something and it's true
yeah I do think it's really funny that
mbaku isn't he like am I wrong to see
live in a cave in a cave yes so he goes
from that to running the most advanced
technological
civilization of all time yeah you're
right that's like the majority of the
movie that we would see I think it's
kind of in turn yeah it's like it's like
you know it's the lighter side you know
it's the lighter side of Marvel where
where we get a little light-hearted fun
of him
you know control all deleting the
computers or maybe it sounds like that
movie Dave you know the guy they have to
like oh yeah uh sure them through
running the being the leader of the free
world yes yes Encino man yeah okay
Tommy I'm gonna give you one Rogge great
and this is for you I'm passing it to
you through the camera great there you
go you turned it into an original Egon
Spengler only 15 minutes in before Tommy
short everybody is Spangler one of the
perks of being in your childhood home is
that you can play with your childhood
toys you started that call we're talking
about your quarantine with your mom yeah
you keep connecting those dots Phillip
you do you I can't write your fanfiction
about me that's got to come from your
heart I feel like of all the people here
you are the most likely to write your
own fanfic that's very true I have
archives of it if you ever want to read
it's 400 pages long mostly drawings all
right Tommy I say use a boat mbaku 2020s
are you saying yeah me and Egon say that
it by the way you're gonna want to give
me some more druggies because I've got
some great stuff here
okay well make sure we can show it on
camera Matt what do you got all right so
I like I like to kill monger theory I'm
into MANET for president I'll vote but I
think you guys are sleeping on this
underwater earthquake you mentioned it
at the top of it we're not talking about
it yes thank you somebody's listening
right all right I was I here's the thing
okay so we know we know that what
condoms are first to fight right for our
knowledge to the best of our knowledge
they had absolutely
no concept of alien life and yet the
moment that Thanos his army came down
they were ready they were like we're
ready they're doing the the Bombay's
they are ready to fight these guys right
so nobody that's the test to become air
you have to be the dog was conjoined
dogs okay
great theory Matt okay so pick it up
there was an earthquake not wanted to
deal with it okay I said not to worry
we're handling it in theory that's kind
of a badass statement so my guess is the
underwater earthquake that we perceived
is actually some kind of underwater
battle that is happening double content
design step into which leads us into to
the best characters in the MCU well the
Marvel Universe hoping to be the MCU
tiger shark Namor I'm telling you guys
this is the way they work them in I
think this is how we we kind of backfill
Namor into the ncu I think it's a great
way that you have Atlantis you have
Wakanda
you have two of these kind of like very
proud and tribal nations going
head-to-head and this is the war that's
gonna spill out into the modern world
and into what we're dealing with I'm
just excited to have Namor in the MCU
and I think it's even better because
it's only gonna lead to the greatest
team of all time the defenders which as
everyone knows here is Namor Hulk
Doctor Strange and Silver Surfer which
maybe we'll get one day but I'm very
upset
Wow I'm gonna I'm gonna like poke around
here with your time
so we know we know that five years have
passed yeah and then there's the
earthquake yeah under the water so what
were the five years leading up to that
earthquake this is that this is a
brimming war this is like the earthquake
was essentially the the first time that
these two tribes these two nations
actually came together I mean if you
think about it for us to feel an
earthquake under water it has to be
pretty seismic right it's not just like
a regular earthquake and like LA or
whatever it has to be kind of massive
for us to actually register it on any
kind of scales so I think that over the
last five years
Okoye has kind of in charge hernán j'l
Abbasid are getting their groove back
and they're kind of taking things on and
all of a sudden all of a sudden they
start to see this this nation rising up
from the sea and trying to take things
over cuz everyone knows that Landon's
are bad people they hate they hate the
surface walkers they hate us for
breathing air and ruining their there
the water coca-cola factory yeah exactly
exactly so we know that they're
definitely not going to start off as
being friendly people so of course what
conda's on the front lines taking them
out and I think the earthquake of what
we saw is probably what we were probably
interpret as a massive world war
happening underwater this battle
you know akin to an act three of Aquaman
but a massive fight that's happening
between wakandans and Atlanteans and
we're just registering it now which is
why echo a was kind of like don't worry
about it we got it covered it's all good
that's what my theory is that is my fear
you're talking about the massive end of
the conflict that sounds like a world
war but where does it start
I mean you've already got it in real
life right you've got the fact that like
Atlanteans have a reason to be upset at
you know earthlings right because we're
ruining their their area so I would say
that it would be something along the
lines is you know possibly Atlanteans
coming up and trying to destroy tree
life or destroy modern technology and
what better place to start than a place
that is already so advanced
technologically than what Conda so I'd
say that it was probably some kind of
sleeper probably some kind of you know
possibly a bomb possibly somebody who
set up to destroy something public and
that was what put it on the radar for
Wakanda though to say I would assume
based on their intelligence what kind of
probably knew Atlanta existed Atlanta
Georgia
existed yeah but a Hotlanta but but I
think that that's directed by Tyler
Perry
exactly exactly starring childish
gambino I think that honestly having
having this war starts in Wakanda and
then hope you know the wakandans trying
to keep it contained in their world and
it brimming to the point and five years
later and then all of a sudden in the
midst of this massive war these battles
are happening all of a sudden the rest
of the wakandan people show up as well
as the most powerful superheroes on the
planet all decided to show up I'm
assuming that there's gonna be a beat
taken on this war and we're gonna see
something happen even bigger in the
future now that everyone's back on earth
that's my guess all right Matt you've
got and you've earned your first Rogie
so much for giving me this Magic the
Gathering car condom oh my god oh I'm
sorry I'll give you a second thank you
back to one all right let's hear
everyone's theories back in a tweet
starting with Erik okay where did we go
in half of everyone snapped well if
you're what Condon you went to the
ancestral plane and it's now a choice
between you and the other black panther
head sisters over which champion
deserves to inherit the throne
Okoye yay or kill mongers you're on
adventure twenty characters your player
[Laughter]
Eric's on the blue screen so he can do
something with it all right
Tommy what he got mbaku how dare you to
Chawla must come back from dust make
Wakanda great again
that's embarked as campaign no that's me
as a grassroots muckraker for the Rakata
times they're like why is that fat white
guy writing for that paper under the
raid
I'm the Michael Miller of Wakanda I just
go around Oh God
dirty in the water and recording huh
that's right
what's your wakandan name what kind of
name is man I almost said something
really mean about myself my mikado name
is big boy big beefy boy
Oh big boy yes sir I think you could
just - just milady
that's gonna be my milady my boy I'm a
big boy but I appreciate that
big boy we're not milady
the quarantine playing with your stuff
and then Matt lets you tweet every word
and vision it in between clap emojis so
it's just all sleeping on underwater
earthquake name we're coming y'all
extra point fish emoji and then a little
I think there's a trident emoji it might
not sure it's like this it's it's yeah
there's male and female mermaid emojis
as well both with trunk oh oh I'm gonna
put those in as well though I think the
fish one is pretty more it's pretty
succinct but I like that yeah so y'all
sleep in underwater earthquakes all
right Matt you tweet gets another Rogi
and this is the only time we're moist
makes sense
so since we're talking about being
underwater oh I get my I thank you I get
it back thank you I'm still still moist
2020 and make America moist again all
right guys before we move on really
quick I just a quick shout out to our
sponsors thank you so much to AMC
shudder so AMC shudders kind of like the
Netflix of horror and because we're all
just stuck in our homes kind of scared I
figured let's go ahead and just think
about things that scare us so they're
declaring April the halfway to Halloween
mark and we're just gonna go ahead and
start getting scared at home you guys
can do it with us by watching their new
series of cursed films these are movies
that deal with curses like The Exorcist
is on there my one of my personal
favorites of all time
poltergeists on there and then the crow
which is actually like a cursed film
like all of these movies that you guys
know what we're talking about here right
it's like movies that not only is a
movie kind of about scary stuff but the
production of the movie is really crazy
one field of dream of those Field of
Dreams is cursed all those baseball
players disappeared in the cornfield
well cuz they only death yeah there were
actors actors to my knowledge all the
actors disappeared were never seen again
we're never seen again check Evan
Costner Houston yeah he's he's he was on
this hangout what point they also by the
way they have just other great stuff
related to horror like Robert Kirkman is
the walking dead guy and he's got a
whole series on there of the history of
comics funny enough so it's a even if
you're not a huge horror fan you can
watch that there's also Wolf Creek and
Creepshow TV which is the classic creep
show I do love creep show anytime you
can get Leslie Nielsen in a serious role
just cling on to it it's gold it's
amazing it's a rarity
so shutter has a ton of great thrillers
and horrors and supernatural movies and
TV shows and you can stream them on any
device that you normally stream on it's
just I think it's just $5.99 a month to
it's nothing well enough so they're
offering a free month right now if you
use our promo code I get started
streaming with the best horror thriller
and supernatural content shudders
expertly curated collection includes
titles like Halloween old boy and all of
the Friday the 13th movies even the like
not great eighth one so just try
shredder for free for 30 days go to
shudder calm use promo code new rock
stars
that's Shu dde are calm and use promo
code new rock shows for 30 days free hey
guys are you guys confident in the
bedroom it's my most confident room next
to the bathroom wait are we talking
sexually or like how I sleep right well
do you like sleeping with boners oh yes
I mean yeah I can't go to sleep it's
impossible the blood has to leave my
body so that I can fall I usually count
on boners to spring me out of bed after
I sleep on my belly but lately it's been
kind of a challenge
well Eric as you know the blue dungeon
it has come out with its own product the
blue Chu
it's actually not at all relationship
loo dungeon it just happens to be you
chew guys okay that's not the blue true
we haven't sent it to you yet oh no
wonder it's not working thank God it's
not working guys blue Chu is a chewable
pill equivalent basically an alternative
to Viagra or Cialis but they're cheaper
than both of those and they're made in
the USA oh yeah raised raised that
flagpole and also you'd have to do the
awkward thing of going to your doctor or
your pharmacy and screaming at them I
can't get it up which is I assume how
you get prescribed screaming on the
street yeah but you got to scream at a
pharmacist you got to try that
everybody's got their kink mine shouting
let's cool about this as blue - just as
a free online consultation with the
doctor and then once they approve you
they just ship it directly to your door
and real a discreet packaging I have
said this multiple times that I'd be
proud of it means you're getting laid if
it's the mail so like I don't mind it
showing up here's the really great deal
they're giving us you go to blue to calm
and you get your first order free when
you use promo code new rock very clear
on there again new rock new rock yards
yeah new rock cards everyone knows what
we could have said people in the
comments like they should have said that
you we know use promo code new rock and
you just got to pay five bucks for the
shipping but if your sex life isn't
worth by bucks I mean you could just
have it and just if you're bored around
the house just take it just certain
stuff for turning the light switch on
and off if you need something to hang
your sweater on take a blue yeah
honestly without a blue shoe I don't
know that I can hit all these light
switches it depends if it's the easy
like flip one or is it like the knob
that you have to push in and then twist
no it's it's the cockers you got it it's
the cockers that's what they call them
can you take 1 blue 2 you will be able
to turn up all the light switches into
your apartment at the same time with
your proven with your wieners mind so
you turn into a fantastic by that Eric
saying you will black out all the lights
go because all the blood rush
oh my god I turned on the lights off and
I woke up in a hospital blue cheese
stock has quadrupled blue to calm your
Omo code new rock guys it's time to talk
about the discord theory of the week and
announce our winner by the way so if you
don't know we've been playing a version
of this that is much less rocky in the
discord with our patrons where they get
to pitch their theories
this week's theory let's see was about
who's gonna be the next big bad in the
MCU after Thanos we had really great
theories from teens and also damn wig I
like teens was really rogue and so was
damn wigs actually I really like both of
their theories this is the first - okay
the vote was very close the winner was
just by one vote well three judges split
their vote everyone liked a different
one but our winner is
MLG X champion it's who also is known as
Ritchie and his theory is that much like
how Thanos was built up over a bunch of
phases actually our Big Big Bad is gonna
be delayed for a while it will be a
dozen or so movies before we deal with
Galactus but in the meantime we're
hitting beats of Mini not mini villains
but our smaller villains specifically
Kang coming in and helping introduce the
Fantastic Four and the Thunderbolts also
playing smaller building roles along the
way there's really great details they're
also about in damn wigs theory I really
liked about how the Fantastic Four movie
could be set in the past I know Eric
likes that idea too
I love that I think that's awesome I
think it's genius I love the concept of
using Kang is kind of a mini boss you
could use Kang you use Silver Surfer you
could use any of the early FF villains I
think that's genius EDD I love the idea
of not getting another big bad for like
10 more years like let's give it a beat
like the world just destroyed like
what's what's wait a minute
I completely agree patience well and
Kang being able to travel through time
does set up you could we could have
already had the Fantastic Four this
whole time in the 60s or something yeah
you have their whole series take place
there or something totally yeah I love
that and I think you need some time to
build up to Galactus cuz I think he's
most effective as just like this Specter
wet looming in the background and then
we start to get used to the idea of him
and then like two phases later finally
we get there all right guys time for our
final big theory it is about a debate
that was going on on Twitter this week I
know if you guys saw there's a heated
debate about essentially which Marvel
movie is more skippable floor to or Iron
Man 3 these are basically the Marvel
movies they have the lowest Rotten
Tomatoes score other candidates that
people threw in there were the
Incredible Hulk Captain Marvel was up
there too
so all these MCU movies are very fun
we're doing our rewatch right now we're
really enjoying it and they're all
better than like Catwoman and daredevil
of that movie but pitch me on what you
guys think is the most skippable of the
MCU movies if you must skip one because
you're you know you're having a baby I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go really Road that's
that's that's the point yeah I'm gonna
say these are this is where you can stop
I think you could lose the last 20
minutes of Avengers and the first 90
minutes of Avengers 2 it'd be completely
fine I don't I find nothing of value in
those when people ask me to discuss
those movies I don't remember what
happens in them they don't reach me the
you know as the storytelling the way
that the smaller singular standalone
movies are I like when the characters
come from other other stories into the
standalone movies when they all get
together except for Avengers 3 or 4
which I thought were home runs for
movies the first two I thought really
were kind of clunky and forgettable
films is it don't they win at the end of
Avengers 1 in the last 20 minutes mm-hmm
who cares so we don't need to know that
obviously they wait guys
pretty clear Tommy you want to pause
right in the middle of the battle in New
York that's right right when Hulk shows
up and says I'm always a as he turns he
never becomes Hulk it just goes
Tony flies include the world obviously
I'm being dramatic but I just I honestly
think I have to pick a movie Avengers 2
is one I would skip every time I just
don't like I never remember that movie I
always my number one question when
people talk about that movie is can you
remind me what happens then with me
again like really what we get is the
Scarlet Witch we lose Quicksilver in
kind of a hokey way like having him die
was kind of a cop-out because the
character was so popular in the Fox
x-men movies they didn't really have a
way to do it like obviously can do the
magneto being their father storyline so
they kind of just killed him to give her
the motivation to be good I guess but I
don't know is bader quoting Pinocchio is
worth my $20 with you and I love James
Spader and I don't hate out of curiosity
Erik you do a James Spader impression
right after Bluetooth Tommy I avenged -
I'm gonna give you - Rogi yes for that
thank you thank you oh my gosh they
turned into wow this is totally crazy I
wasn't expecting this another another
Egon I think this is a Ghostbusters
extreme Egon and a grenade we don't put
it down yeah I think it's a dud you know
the fact that these were your your toys
were the same figurine multiple times
and then a grenade yeah it sounds a lot
about the person you become a bird if
you didn't own two Egan's you didn't
come correct and you were gonna get that
you were gonna get shot down so yeah it
was a 2e guns and a knockoff Slimer
that's actually a grenade you've never
heard that would tank song - Egon say
grenade killer
Ghostface Killah makes sense
who's next I'm most disappointed I've
ever been in an MCU movie was ant-man I
feel like I and it's upsetting cuz it's
like on paper I love every aspect I
really would have loved if they just
give an attack or write a hundred
percent it would have been a completely
different movie and I would have loved
it so going in it was already like this
already feels imagine eyes love anything
Paul Rudd does huge fan I I think Peyton
Reed
my number one favorite movie of all time
is down with love so you tell me he's
doing a superhero movie about kind of a
d-list superhero I was like oh my god
I'm in it just felt so unnecessary it
felt colored by numbers Marvel at the
end of the day if you start with a man
too and you're like here he is a suit
he's super cute he's super charming he's
super relatable also you you've got wasp
she's already a thing she exists I don't
need an entire movie of her trying to
prove herself to set it up like I get it
she's a badass
she doesn't need quarantine akai
understand but I think like you can
genuinely skip that entire first movie
and you'll be fine like it doesn't it
doesn't need to exist in your brain it
doesn't I agree I switch my answer to
his answer oh good yeah I'll give you
this you can give him one of and what
does Matt turn it into it oh no I turned
it into a Batman that's so cute so what
you do is you met you melt the wax and
then you stamp it oh my god you're like
a lord to the right word for it oh man
bad man in Westeros let's pitch that
next time Bester I okay yeah I mean
ant-man was it was yeah I think you just
you nailed it right it's like it's a fun
movie and then I forgot happened he said
that yep but then has the most violent
death you've ever seen in any of the MCU
movies he murders Frank and wipes him up
off the floor and floor it is disgusting
it is what is the most like violent
kills every but it couldn't it couldn't
remember that you had to literally
describe it verbatim for me to remember
yeah all right so you got your Rogi from
Tommy and Tommy came up when a busy
alright Eric what do you got okay I
think the debate between Thor 2 and Iron
Man 3 is little unfair because we're in
phase 2 we're still figuring it out and
yeah I think some of those phase 1
movies I'm willing to forgive because
Marvel was still like
getting its footing I think Thor 2 and
Iron Man three are unfairly maligned I
think there's a lot of good things about
that movie both those movies really to
me the I'm gonna get some hate for this
I think Captain Marvel was very
disappointing in a lot of ways and my
favorite things about that movie is
everything that is not related to the
character of Carol Danvers I think
there's so much about that character and
her journey that I think is completely
skippable and I think they did so many
things to fix that character and make
her a leader and make her active and
make her interesting and focused an end
game and if they had just let yeah maybe
her introduction to the MCU I think it
would have been completely fine and if
they had just titled the story of
Captain Marvel Nick Fury and the origin
of the Avengers initiative it would have
been a far more interesting film that's
fair I like the idea Nick Fury
accidentally almost getting as I poke
down for ninety minutes I feel like I've
watched Oh glass factory Olsen took blue
tube BAM and it's got a fork tip if this
story had just been Nick Fury and goose
for the whole time could have been like
a Turner and hooch kind of thing a buddy
comedy that would have been an amazing
film yeah you know the difference of
filmmakers to write like does the end
game filmmakers you know it's fun to
have Captain Marvel in that movie and
then Captain Marvel isn't she's not fun
until the end of her own movie yeah and
even then she gets in these superhero
complex where her powers are too
powerful she's a little undefined what
she can and can't do she'll like go
super saiyan and they shipped through
everything she can move at Lightspeed
it's kind of like well then how is she
specifically useful in this she's -
she's giving us a reason why century
could never exist in the MCU right right
and also a great reason for why we need
to send her as far away for many movies
as possible yeah if she can like but
Wilson will give her a beeper and then
if we can use her only moment when we
can't think of our way out of us
but Eric you got a Rogi it bums me out
but you're right yeah Oh turn into it's
gonna turn into a manscaped
not a sponsor of this episode not a
sponsor but boy oh boy is this gotten me
through this quarantine period Eric can
you pass that back to me yeah here you
go Philip you I wanted the Rogi back
forget it
wait try it yeah wait if I give you the
manscaped wait a grenade for your pubic
area God all right so let's hear him
back again in a Tweaker Avengers to
screw you I'll take a standalone movie
like Black Widow kiddo
no Tommy's like Phineas Gage you got a a
bar REE Barbarin is brain and you can
only tweet and right now I'm traveling
around the country for five cents an
hour telling my story great next tweet
so if Portman's coming back Thor to
actually matters I think you're all
wrong ant-man is the worst keep recap
look maybe you was your point about
ant-man blacked out for a second I'm
sorry when the blue tube kicks in and
then Eric what do you got the
post-credits scene two Avengers infinity
war just went on a couple seconds too
long instead of panning down to that
beeper to show the Captain Marvel logo
it's just of let Nick Fury finish this
word which wasn't going to be much
it was gonna be motherf lurking just a
buddy comedy with him and goose is all
we need man Eric's tweet these little
mini essays I didn't turns up notes and
then post the mystery oh there's
screenshots wait we could do that I take
my back Tommy your tweet Gallimore great
Wow
yeah it's this old lady Ghostbuster
character that all Ghostbusters toys in
one day in late 1985 damn like stamps on
this one was made in 1988 good plastic
that used to make good toys guys Eric
was made in 1988 and he's my favorite
toy time for ugh questions all right
guys all right number one Daniel Craig
said in a recent interview that he plans
to give away all of his money before he
dies instead of leaving it to his
children what's the most bond reason for
having to cut off his kids cuz those
babies are shaken not stirred shaken
babies yeah it's not alive or also just
slept with so many women he doesn't know
that they're his kids so you that's
exactly a thousands of kids yeah he's
had unprotected sex with a woman in
every movie for the last 50 years give
it away or maybe the bond reason is that
like his movies over the past decade
every other one is a dud Scott Z burns
who wrote these suddenly very topical
movie Contagion is currently working on
a musical for AMC what's the title of
the coronavirus themed musical social
disc dancing social distance maybe
avenue achoo good no rent
oh yes right freeze oh yeah
rent freeze please actual freeze and
then number three the release of the
upcoming film minions rise of GRU was
being delayed and I'm really am
about this I'm actually really bummed I
was really we're gonna need minions
right now I also so we're gonna send
these to Universal guys give us your
best impassioned plea to the studio of
why they need to release minions rise of
Group right now dear Kung Fu Panda
I assume based on Universal Studios you
are the god of Universal so I'll appeal
directly to you release the minions we
need the minions a lot of people don't
know this but minions are important to
children and adults alike if you keep
the Dominions from me I can't be held
responsible for what I'll do you think
the rise of grows upsetting where do you
see the rise of Tommy sponsored by blue
Chu mine is very simple without minions
what are we supposed to masturbate to
get your [ __ ] together Universal is
right get it together
dammit he's right and Eric minions is
love that's track you can't take Shrek's
thing that's all he has he's right Matt
and Tommy you both get an additional
Rogi oh my god it's this is crazy it's
Wonder Woman and Chris has kept America
in a 69 that's crazy Rogi yeah it's a
pretty crazy from you can I go you got I
get I got one can you pass it at me and
commit to the bed and pass it to you
right now now I don't forget off the
ground yeah well well thank you anyway
it's a it's a pin of me Oh
[Music]
all those places where your soul should
be exactly where my eyes would be is
just the void of nothingness really know
stuff lurk and yeah all right guys let's
do a count your oh geez I have no idea
three one four I have five rookies I
have three roadies I don't remember how
many I have oh no I do I have four I
have my magic card and my moist pin and
my pin and this seal of Batman oh yeah
that's right now I have four and Matt
has five because I gave him one of
myself right so now
have I have too many I run out of Oh
Matt has five Matt if you'll admit that
that a Batman thing is definitely uh
just many little vibrator because that's
more what it looks like then you are our
winner luckily it's just for me Matt we
forgot to tell you this the winner has
is a wish come true here at the end of
the episode so teachers have a wish for
us that we can enact right now oh my
wish black widow never comes out well
for the time being we'll make that true
guys that's it for this episode of rogue
theory
I think story I guess - Matt Rob even
though I do not agree with what he just
wished for no no you think you meant
granted it it's not on me it's on you
this is the new rock star thing if the
movie never comes out there's like that
seal on that wish I'm vibrating Betsy
Tommy Bechtold thank you so much and
then Eric what do we have going on in
the channel this week well you know
we've been we've been going through all
these em serie watches of the Infinity
Saga Hulk will be on the channel
tomorrow and then on Monday we'll have
Iron Man - if all things go okay
whiplash
alright guys that's it for this episode
of rogue theory thanks for everybody for
joining do not forget to subscribe to
work there's a podcast - and also did
this channel and follow dr serbs on
twitter at new rock stars follow me
anywhere I felt Melina Instagram Twitter
all these people's handles were on their
faces of minute ago we're doing it it's
happening yeah Internet